تلقت الارض شحنه خاصه
انها اكبر عينه صخريه حتى الان من كويكب
لحظه تاريخيه انتظرها العلماء بفارغ الصبر
في صحراء ولايه يوتا الامريكيه هبطت
الكبسوله الفضائيه بنجاح على الارض وعلى
متنها العينه بعد ان اسقطها المصبار
وسايرس
اتبعوا لوكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا
العينه ذات قيمه علميه كبيره وقد تحمل
ادله محتمله لاصل الحياه على الارض تقدر
ناسا العينه بنحو 250 غراما من المواد
التي انتزعت من الكويكبينو لتختتم بذلك
مهمه استمرت سبع سنوات وكلفت اكثر من
مليار دولار
ونقلت العينه الى مختبرات ناسا في التكساس
لفحصها من قبل عشرات العلماء مستخدمين
مناهج بحث مختلفه لتحليل الصخور والغبار
من الكويكب الحصول على ادله بشان كيفيه
بدء الحياه على الارض
وكانت المركبه الفضائيه
اكس قد انطلقت من محطه الفضاء
بولايه فلوريدا عام 2016
وامضت المركبه عامين في التحليق بالقرب من
الصخره الفضائيه القديمه وحولها قبل جمع
الركام من السطح في اكتوبر 2020
يامل العلماء الكشف عن بعض اسرار النظام
الشمسي من خلال العينات الماخوذه من سطح
بينو المظلم والخشن والغني بالكربون ويقدر
عرض الكويكب باربع مئه وتسعين مترا اما
عمره فاربعه مليارات وخمسمائه مليون سنه
ويعتقد ان بينو الذي يعد قطعه مكسوره من
كواكب اكبر يحتوي على اللبنات الاساسيه
للنظام الشمسي يمكن للعينات الماخوذه ان
تلقي الضوء على كيفيه تشكل الكواكب ونشوء
الحياه على الارض كما يمكنها ايضا تحسين
احتمالات اصطدام الارض باي كويكبات قادمه